معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد مقتل جندي اصابه ضابط و
فاتوره هذه الحرب بالنسبه لخسائر الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى ارتفاع كيف يتعامل مع
الجانب
الاسرائيلي الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن عن مقتل
جندي واصابه ثلاثه بينهم ضابط بجراح خطيره
في معارك بجنوب قطاع غزه وبذلك يكون قد
ارتفع مجمل قتلاه منذ عمليه طوفان الاقصى
وبدايه الحرب على غزه التي تدخل اليوم
يومها ال 107 يرتفع الى
531 قتيلا بينهم 202 قتلوا منذ ان بدا
حربه البريه في ال 26 وال من اكتوبر
الماضي هذه الخسائر واضح بانها تقلق
الاسرائيليين هو اعلن ايضا انه خلال ال 2
ساعه الماضيه كان هناك 16 جنديا وضابطا قد
اصيبوا لكن التطور الذي يحصل على خلفيه
هذا كله وفي محاوله للتقليل من الاصابات
والقتلى في صفوف قواته اعلن عن انه قد
انتقل الى مرحله جديده من اساليب القتال
في قطاع غزه والتي تقوم على اشن غارات او
ما يسميها بالاستهداف المركز اي ان يقوم
بشن غارات على اهداف محدده في قلب المواقع
الفلسطينيه في تحديدا في جنوبي القطاع
بالامس كان قد عاد في ساعات المساء ودفع
بتعزيزات بارتل من الدبابات الى منطقه
خانيونس التي يعتبرها المعقل الاساسي
للمقاومه وتحديدا لكتائب القسام وحركه
حماس وفي تلك المنطقه يقوم ايضا بعمليات
تدمير وتفجير واسعه فوق الارض وتحت الارض
مدعيا انه قد عثر على شبكات انفاق فيها
هذا الوضع مقلق للاسرائيليين لكنه ايضا
يزيد من حاله الجدل فيذا داخل الشارع
الاسرائيلي هذا الشارع الذي شهد الليله
الماضيه اربعه مظاهرات في حيفا وفي
قيساريا قباله منزل رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
وكذلك في القدس الغربيه والاهم هو في
منطقه تلبيب وتحديدا فيما بات يعرف بميدان
المخطوفين او المختطفين وفي منطقه محيط
الكرياه وهي مجمع قياده الجيش والاجهزه
الامنيه ورئاسه الوزراء ووزاره الدفاع هذه
المظاهرات بدات ترفع شعارات سياسيه ليس
كما كانت كل الفتره الماضيه تدعو فقط ل ان
يكون هناك افراج عن كافه او اعاده كافه
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه والذين
يقدر عددهم ب
136 وانما ترفع شعارات سياسيه تدعو الى
اسقاط نتنياهو
وحكومته والذهاب الى انتخابات جديده من من
اجل اختيار
حكومه جديده وتحم حمل نتنياهو
المسؤوليه كامله عما الى اليه الوضع سواء
الفشل الاستخباري والامني والعسكري في خ
في السابع من اكتوبر الماضي او خلال اداره
هذه الحرب لا سما وان الشارع بدا يستشعر
من خلال ما يتم تسريبه من معلومات عن
خلافات وسجالات داخل دوائر صنع القرار بان
هناك مشكله كبيره في راس الهدم الهرم
اسرائيلي من ناحيه اتخاذ القرارات وتردد
نتنياهو حتى الان او مماطلته في ان يكون
هناك استراتيجيه واضحه سياسيه واضحه لهذه
الحرب وايضا تفاقم ما ك اصبح يعرف بالخلاف
مع الاداره الامريكيه اصبح مقلقا لقطاعات
متزايده في الشارع الاسرائيلي وعلى مستوى
النخب وايضا
ال دائره القرار نفسها لا سي ما داخلها من
توتر سواء بين وزير الدفاع جلنت ورئيس
الحكومه نتنياهو من ناحيه او بين نتنياهو
وال الوزيرين في مجلس الحرب ايزنكوت وبيني
جانس من المعسكر الدوله ويبدو ان هناك
خلاف حول تحديد اهداف هذه الحرب حيث
يتهمون نتنياهو بانه قد تنصل نهائيا من ان
تكون قضيه اعاده الاسرائيليين المحتجزين
في غزه على راس الا
ويريد المضي ويريد المضي في هذه الحرب الى
اطول مده ممكنه لتحقيق مكاسب سياسيه حزبيه
خاصه في هذه النقطه فقط ننوه ل هذا الخبر
العاجل اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي عن زعيم
المعارضه يقول اكدت في الكنيسه دع اي صفقه
التبادل حتى لو كلفتنا وقف اطلاق النار ما
الذي نفهمه من هذا
الموقف هذا الموقف هو يعكس تعزيز هذا
التوجه داخل الشارع اسرائيلي هذا ما يريده
قطاع متوا متزايد من الشارع الاسرائيلي
ليس فقط ذوي الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في
قطاع غزه وهو ايضا ما يدعو اليه وزراء
كبار داخل مجلس الحرب تحديدا ايزن قط وبني
جانس الذين اعلنا ذلك صراحه الاسبوع
الماضي بانه يجب العمل على ابرامي صفقه
تبادل اولا حتى لو كانت الكل في مقابل
الكل واعاده جميع اسرائيليين المحتجزين
لذلك تصريح زعيم المعارضه يائير لبيد يصب
في هذه القناه وهذه مناقضه تماما للاتجاه
في داخل اوساط نتنياهو نتنياهو ومن هم من
حوله يريدون المضي في هذه الحرب الى اطول
مده ممكنه ولم يخفوا ذلك وقالوا بان اي
وقف لاطلاق النار حاليا سيتم تفسيره وكانه
انتصار او انجاز لحركه حماس وبالامس كان
قد ادعى الاسرائيليون بان حركه حماس قد
بعثت بردها وشروطها على قضيه ابرام صفقه
لتبادل الاسرى حددت فيها بان الخطوه
الاولى يجب ان تكون وقفا تاما لاطلاق
النار وانهاء الاعمال القتاليه الخطوه
الثانيه انسحاب كامل للجيش الاسرائيلي من
قطاع غزه والخطوه الثالثه هي ابرام صفقه
تبادل شامله وايضا ضمان بقاء حركه حماس
كسلطان غزه شكرا جزيلا لك وليد العمري
مدير مكتبنا من رام الله